c'est à plusieurs mètres sous terre au
coeur des vestiges de la rotonde que les
archéologues viennent de faire l'une des
plus grandes découvertes du chantier
dans une petite cour entre la sacristie
et le chevet de la cathédrale se cacher
depuis des centaines d'années un
véritable trésor on a ce chapiteau là
par exemple qui est tout à fait
remarquable avec ses systèmes de deux
représentations végétal avec le fus de
la colonne et compris avec sa petite
sont issus port ce petit vase
et on ad'un retrouve aussi un autre
chapiteau ici exactement dans
l'alignement dans sa disposition
d'origine avec sa sa base et son fut une
découverte qui révèlent de précieux
indices sur l'utilisation de ces lieux
au xième siècle
on a retrouvé aussi un autre indice très
intéressant c'est que ce sont des
systèmes de banquettes sur laquelle on
pouvait s'asseoir les banquettes ont
disparu mais on n'en voit que l'enduit
s'arrête au dessus du niveau du sol un
petit peu en hauteur et ses banquettes
et bien sont en rapport avec l'usagé
l'utilisation de cet espace par les
pèlerins qui venaient de très loin et
qu'ils faisaient plusieurs dizaines
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres pour
venir se recueillir sur le tombeau de
saint bénigne et est donc forcément il
était fatigué mais aussi il devait
rester ici plusieurs heures plusieurs
jours désormais intégré au futur plan de
visite pour le public cette découverte
rebat également les cartes concernant
l'histoire de ce monument unique du
patrimoine on découvre que le plan est
encore plus compliqué que celui que l'on
connaissait notamment par les gravures
les relevés du xviiie siècle et les
fouilles qui ont été réalisés dans les
années 1970 on a encore un plan
plus compliqué qui évoquent et permet de
réinterpréter toute la liturgie qui se
faisait à l'intérieur de cet automne
encore dans sa phase d'assainissement le
chantier de la route on livre de nouveau
secret mais gardent aussi ses mystères
la découverte de cet escalier similaires
à ceux de la mosquée sainte sophie à
istanbul questionne les archéologues
les escaliers hélicoïdaux on en a
partout dans tous les édifices du
moyen-âge mais la grande particularité
c'est effectivement ce noyau central est
vide et en général ils sont pleins alors
on peut poser les quêtes différentes
questions soient si une technique de
fondations très particulière ou alors on
se demandait si c'est pas un système de
puits de lumière pour éclairer cet
escalier des découvertes archéologiques
auquel s'ajoute un peu plus haut tout un
travail de conservation c'est l'enjeu du
chantier de rénovation de la sacristie
usé par le temps où plus de cent mètres
cubes de pierres de taille datant du 19e
siècle ont été remplacées par de
nouvelles pierre de bourgogne en objet
de démonter complètement certaines
parties c'est le cas de ce pignon voyez
donc la partie triangulaire qui est
devant la charpente et qui a été
entièrement démontées et qui en ce
moment entièrement remonté avec des
pierres neuves intégralement par exemple
pour l'entourage de cet opus circulaire
mais ici nous avons remonté des pierres
anciennes et on les marie avec des
pierres neuves
cent cinquante ans après sa construction
la sacristie de la cathédrale
saint-bénigne retrouve une seconde
jeunesse sa rénovation devrait être
achevé à la fin de l'année deux ans de
travaux seront encore nécessaires pour
rénover la crypte et la rotonde la
grande dame du patrimoine bourguignon
pourrait bien nous révéler de nouveaux
secrets
[Musique]